hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the swish wallet podcast and with
Father's Day creeping up on us now is
the perfect time to get in early and
surprise your dad with that perfect gift
now you could get him some chocolates
some socks or some undies but if your
dad likes sport then the perfect option
to get him is a swish from his favorite
sport star it is the best Father's Day
gift out to order head over to
heyswish.com and you can even get 10 off
your purchase by using the code dead 10
and remember that up to 70 of the
proceeds do go to Kiwi kids Charities so
you can also tell your dad that he
donated to what is a really good cause
I'll leave a link in the description
below so just go click on that and go
get your dad the gift he really deserves
this Father's Day also if your old man
has muscle or joint aches which are
anything like mine another great gift
idea for this Father's Day is some pure
sport products the CBD oil and the
muscle balm have been massive to helping
me get through a very difficult hip
surgery and from hearing other customers
feedback as well they're all in the same
boat and so just because you're a lad
and you're listening to some water lead
and you can get 20 off any of the
products by using the code Borderland
20. I'll leave a link in the description
below so you can just click on that and
go get amongst it and last but not least
the absolutely ad Tim Bateman has an
opportunity for you to own your very own
o studio so I went down and checked out
o studio for the very first time the
other week down in Christchurch and it
is such a cool setup float tanks
recovery rooms saunas ice baths yoga
meditation rooms it's got it all and
it's such a cool space for just clearing
your head and recovering your body and
your mind and with the well-being
industry being the second fastest
growing industry in the world this is
the perfect time to get involved and
learning from the goat Tim Bateman mate
that would be worth the investment alone
if you're interested follow the link in
the description to inquire but anyway
let's get to the show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
oh what a lad well today I have a lad
who came on early in season one with an
episode that became a favorite to the
mini water-led listener an episode where
he told his inspiring story speaking
about his incredible rugby career and
his life post footy and it's that life
post footy Journey that I'm really Keen
to talk about and a little bit more
depth after turning an idea into what
has become UK's latest Wellness brand in
pure sport he is a hell of a lad and a
massive supporter of the podcast so I'm
stoked to have him back on what a lad it
is the great man himself Grayson Hart
welcome brother bloody good to be back
bro I don't warrant such a great intro
but I think it's just you know you
podcast Master these days so you're
you're pretty good at that good to be
back bro mate stoked to have you back on
and I listened to your um first episode
the other day
um just to catch up on it and man that
was a good podcast uh sort of forget
some of these podcasts when you get
through so many how good some of them
were and mate that one was was literally
one of the greats and I'm looking
forward to diving a little bit deeper in
some of those areas yeah man and I
absolutely love to chat with you and um
I just think it's amazing what you're
doing in terms of
giving rugby players a platform to kind
of
give an insight into who they really are
and I think rugby is a game that
has so much sort of like tradition and
and kind of like play as a
sort of always push to kind of stay
within this dear Lane you know as what
and act and be the way people perceive
rugby players should be whereas nowadays
you know it's about people being able to
express themselves and be kind of true
to who they are and it doesn't diminish
or take away from who they are as a
rugby player so you know you're giving
people a platform to do that so I'm a
huge fan of the water lad podcast and
what you're doing bro so bloody good to
be here mate oh I appreciate that and
you're right that is a it is a stigma
that's around that needs to change like
guys do need we do need to see more of
these personalities of players we I
think we are seeing it slightly but
um there's so many as you know there's
so many good lads in those chains of
room personalities different characters
there should be no shame in being
yourself like I feel like there has been
before yeah no 100 man and I think
I feel you know New Zealand Rugby to me
is actually
Leading The Way with that you know like
I can tell
by the way that
the Super Rugby teams sort of like media
um and social media people are
being a bit more light-hearted and
playful with their content allowing
players to kind of joke and interview
each other and show that other side of
the personality that's not just those
bloody boring copy and paste post-match
interviews that we all know so well and
and actually I feel in this day and age
peoples
uh attention is dragged in so many
directions and for a sport a
professional sport to flourish it has to
be more than that 80 minutes uh it has
to be an insight into the behind the
scenes who the players are what the
personalities are yeah and that's why
the sports like UFC and all these are
flourishing because people are I can
connect it and they they align so much
with individuals because they're able to
express themselves
so I do think rugby has been a bit
behind in that regard but I think New
Zealand Rugby to me anyway and my humble
opinion looks like they're breaking that
mold and then podcast like what you're
doing is actually playing a big part in
there I I I find English rugby very
just to speak plainly because I don't
have a great vocabulary so so ungrate
that I couldn't even remember the word
vocabulary but I think it's boring man
and like people are just within their
box you know you have the odd person
like these guys all have personalities
but then you get guys like Finn Russell
or Alice games who do Express themselves
and they just get like shat on by the
public and the media whereas actually
it's like guys for the good of this game
you should be encouraging these people
giving them a platform so yeah that's uh
as you can tell that's a bit of a Spiel
from me right what a star I would love
that what a start to the podcast huge
but I do want to talk about pure sport
from The Outsider and pure sport looks
like it is absolutely humming at the
moment I know you've been through a big
Rebrand as well talk me through the
whole process of the Rebrand and how
it's going yeah bro so
PS4 started as three and a half years
ago now uh I retired two years ago so
the first two years I was playing rugby
uh I started pure sport
because I was on painkillers I've got a
osteoarthritic knee all my cartilage has
gone bone spurs I used to get
cortisone injections every like three
four months I have to get my knee
drained uh of fluid like 100 ml of fluid
once a month
um just popping Coatings and Tramadols
left right and Center to try and train
and play
uh at one point you know they sent me
for a scan because my knee kept swelling
up and the specialist said look like
you're gonna need a knee replacement by
the time you're 40 like you should
retire and and as many of the players
listening to this
can relate to like I was 25 at that time
and I was like no man like this is all
I've got that is my life you know I'll
be back working at the ports of Auckland
and that'll probably be worse for my
knee so
um
and so that for me wasn't an option so I
stuck at it but with the club knowing
that I was struggling and that the
Specialists had sort of said look like
you should retire I became even more
protective of
and I wasn't really being open with the
struggle of how much pain and stuff and
I wasn't getting the right treatment
because I wanted to
stay on the field and keep getting
signed and all of that sort of stuff
and that that's really what led me to
look for natural alternatives away from
the painkillers I actually saw a
teammate
who got addicted to sleeping pills and
it was scary man like he was a good
friend and to the point where he
wouldn't shop to training and stuff and
we were going to the club and being like
man like the screen needs help like he's
really really struggling and
Club [ __ ] they got they just got rid of
them bro like rather than helping him
they just they cut his contract and I
started to see some addictive traits
with like the Tramadols and stuff I was
taking and that's what woke me up to be
like man I need to find natural
alternatives
that's when I researched all sorts tried
all sorts of things found out about CBD
which stands for cannabidiol
which was an extract of the cannabis
plant which doesn't uh it's
non-cycleactive and it has like healing
and therapeutic and Pain Relief and
anti-inflammatory benefits
um and had just been removed off The
Wider list
so I waited till the off season though
because it was obviously not betched
it's the trial that first time in about
a year and a half I was able to train
and function without the painkillers
and for me man like I felt like a new
person my energy levels my mood uh Sleep
Quality gut health everything
felt brand new
so I didn't I just feel like I can't go
back to the painkillers went back to
training on day one of preseason told
the doctor and he and then I was so
surprised he was just like don't take it
if you take it you're gonna bring to
your conduit and I was like can we find
a way can we talk to wider can we talk
to you know and it's just like nap
so that really set me on my journey to
be like I'm gonna find a way still
wasn't a business idea at that point but
along the way I was like actually
I can create the world's first batch
tested and certified for drug tested
athletes range of CBD products
and then along that Journey I'd learned
about all sorts of different
um
things like mushrooms for like neural
cognitive functioning and fighting
against the degeneration of head knocks
and all these things and so I was like
this can be the start of a natural
supplementation brand to kind of
introduce people to some of these game
changing products and rather than the
quick fixes of
Pharmaceuticals like educate on
incorporating like a
a lifestyle around your health
which I've been learning about and yes
so that that's how pure sport came to
life
and in terms of the Rebrand when I
started it was out of my savings you
know to convince my wife that putting my
money into this was a good idea we'd
been saving to try to buy a house and
she you know never done a business
before so she was a bit skeptical but
she backed me went for it but that
savings wasn't a lot you know it wasn't
uh picking up those Japanese contracts
like like and uh and so everything went
into the product development and the
batch testing and and what that meant
was there was nothing left for like
marketing branding design so everything
was made up like I had a graphic
designer that I got off one of those uh
sites called Fiverr uh it's like you
know freelance people when it's not
really affordable and I was just using
like products that my wife had in the
cupboard she loves everybody Cosmetics
so
is like inspiration for like the logos
and and labels and all that so it was
all just really made up uh everything
just went into the quality of the
products and getting that certification
so my my kind of goal with the Rebrand
was okay this business is growing now I
want The Branding and the design and the
website and the packaging to be at the
premium level of these products that
we're creating and innovating and that
are like helping people's lives I want
people to look at it and be like this is
a sick packaging you know like this I'm
buying something premium and this
represents that
so yeah that was that was what it was
and actually I worked with a couple kiwi
fell as a friend from back homes named
Josh his and his guy that he works
alongside with branding stuff the guy
named Elliot Stansfield who's known as
one of New Zealand sort of top graphic
designers in
I'd kind of ran them through my vision
and what I wanted to achieve with the
Rebrand and then they um put together
this these different like presentations
I was like buzzing about it
I still remember the very first time
they actually came with their first
concept I was so excited man jumped on
this call with them they ran me through
like the screen share
and I remember just being like real like
deflated I was like oh [ __ ] because they
were real like buzzing about it and
proud and
and it was cool what they did but it
just wasn't where I had envisioned it
going so that was quite tough because I
was like oh [ __ ] what is that it's not
it's not gonna let the boys down but we
had about four or five different
iterations back and forth from there and
we've got to where it is now which um
yeah man
um so I love it I'm so proud of proud of
it so yeah makes so good such an
inspiring story what you've done to I
can't believe it's only been what like
four years that you've been doing this
and what you've created has been pretty
impressive but one thing you touched on
during that
um start was the addiction to
anti-inflammatories and obviously you
may addicted to sleeping pills what did
your anti-inflammatory intake look like
you said you were close to being
addicted what did that look like because
I'm not such a common problem in rugby
at the moment in sport I'd imagine
people just chomping back their
anti-inflammatories just to get through
the season and get back out on that Park
yeah yeah man like it wasn't until
down the line that I realized like [ __ ]
this is actually an addiction like
because it was so normalized
and for me it was there was no question
to like
I needed to train well and play well
like I wasn't a good enough player that
my performance is on the field for 80
minutes got me you know to start the
following week unfortunately
um and so I had to be competing and
training for my spot every week man like
with the state that my knee was in
and it was frustrating because when you
come up through the ranks in your 19 20
21 like
that level of training and all of that
like that's just who you are like you
just do that we can all relate to that
uh their energy and excitement and
endurance and all that like
so then when I was in sort of like 22 23
24 when I started to struggle with the
knee I was so frustrating man because
you know like I couldn't do all the like
heavy squats and I can you know box
jumps and you know hitting gaps and
training or even like you know when I
when I was signed at Edinburgh which was
at the peak of of the issues they loved
the Box kick over there man and like the
coaches used to get us nines doing so
many box kicks at the end of training
sometimes I think they picked the team
on who who was the the best early box
kicks at the end of training uh and like
that was [ __ ] agonizing for my knee
because every time you're whacking one
of these kicks like you know you're over
extending your knee
and so I was literally
morning
it would be you need to have two or
three training sessions like gym units
uh session and then your main team
session I'll be taking two painkillers
before every session just to mask the
pain to be able to actually train yeah
and then oh man there was times where
after training you know like odd because
I have my little dog it was me and my
little mate my little French Bulldog
Arty named after the Bro Artie Sevilla
um
and I'd want to if I can walk them after
training but so sometimes I'd pop
another two to just be able to walk
around pain free to walk the dog yeah uh
and what happened was that you know they
went from the the voltarens to the
codeines
in those stopped having the same effect
uh to the point where
there was like
four or five months uh at the back end
before I woke up to where I was it was
Tramadols that I was taking and
the reason that I woke up to it was
because like Coatings and that have an
effect
on your mind they can make you drowsy
and stuff I was just chopping coffees to
you know stay alert and all that
but then Tramadol
Tramadol is the type of drug that you
actually when you take it consistently
for a period of time when it's not in
your system you don't feel the same like
you crave it to feel that what you feel
like when it's in your system
and
I remember there's one particular
instance and it must have been probably
like my sixth or seventh tram at all of
the day I was at home watching TV on the
couch after training someone knocked on
the door and was one of these people
like trying to sign you up for a charity
or whatever and
um you know and I'd do my best to
contribute in in here and there but this
time I was like so like off my head that
um
I can't remember the charity and I was
like oh yeah sweet and they like
convinced or they didn't even need to
convince me uh I signed up for like 200
pounds a month uh like referring thing
and then the next day I clicked or I I
was like what the [ __ ] like that's not
I'm not thinking clearly man like I'm
not and you know and and that was a
point where
you know like I said I would be taking
them after training and then they'd wear
off so I'd be like oh okay well I'm not
going to be out I'm not training or
anything it's just the evening but I
feel [ __ ] because it's worn off I take
another two and yeah man that was pretty
scary bro and
seeing then my mate
with sleeping pills and like man
he couldn't get out of bed bro like he
would stay in his dark bedroom the whole
day
uh and we would go around me in like
another Maiden who was friends at the
club and go and be like bro come on man
like let's go out or we'd try to get him
on the way to train to go come on bro
come on
and he'll be at the point where he'd be
like bro I don't care no like I don't
you know
and that was actually like pretty
heartbreaking
experience you know uh to see that
and then when the club wasn't helping
him as a human being they just saw him
as oval he doesn't care
that was dicing on the cake for me to be
like man like you gotta wake up and
as well as you know I spoke to you last
time on on the podcast but I'd seen
addiction happen in my upbringing you
know like my dad struggled with
addiction
I had a cousin uh who I was really close
with who committed suicide uh
being a drug addict his whole life uh
and in my mind that path was just never
like
after what I saw and through my
upbringing
but then to have it normalized
and slip into the slopes that I was
going into
I'm so glad I like woke up from a man
because I don't know you hear about
people that start on these opioid
painkillers and then they're not enough
and you know if I can go off into all
sorts man and it's pretty scary so was
there any other health side effects that
you notice taking this amount of
Tramadols and stuff because obviously
I've had teammates who like you smash
back the anti-inflammatories some of my
teammates have like started pissing like
black and all sorts of weird stuff's
going on to their body did you have
anything like that which sort of made
you realize other than donating all your
money to a charity yeah it was my full
contract
um
so I mean when I look back what what had
happened was
the gradual build up like it became
normal like the the slow build up to
like just this absolutely sub-optimal
state
feeling
came so my new normal because it wasn't
like hey I feel vibrant and good and
clear-minded today
and then oh here's tomorrow and I've and
I've bogged down and my mind's not clear
and I feel hazy and
because all these painkillers it was
like because I had gradually built up
you know Voltaren a couple a day to four
of all time to the encoding to then five
coding to Tramadol
but that's why when I
had that off season when I ordered all
these natural products the CBD products
like capsules oils bombs what I might I
built out this like plan in my mind that
I'm gonna like taper off these
painkillers and like build up these CBD
products and so that took about like two
to three weeks that kind of plan
and it wasn't until I was often probably
for a good
completely off the pancakes for a good
two weeks debt I actually started to
realize what it felt like to have normal
energy levels like a clearer mind
Sleep Quality like it'll become so
normal to be sub-optimal like but what I
realized when I felt good again was that
my Sleep Quality was [ __ ]
my energy levels my mood uh just Clarity
of mind like mood was a huge one man
like all these [ __ ] toxic
opioid Pharmaceuticals they like Cloud
your mind
you know and and I think you know I've
learned that as a human
that we even flow between like feeling
good and clear and like you know
concerned or worried or whatever and
that's pretty normal
but
it's not normal when you just got all
these very extra outside uh
Pharmaceuticals in your system and then
gut health was a big one like
indigestion and inflammation of the guts
and then the knock-on of that of like
diet choices
but the biggest ones are like the mood
energy levels Sleep Quality and gut and
then when I got off them I was like it
was [ __ ] amazing man I was like holy
[ __ ] like this is how I should be
feeling it was yeah so that's why then
for me I was like well I ain't going
back so then when the club was like nah
you bet you can't take those you've got
to take these I was like nah [ __ ] that
I'd rather not be a rugby player than go
back to that you know yeah whereas I
think I was fortunate that I had that
perspective enough at the time that my
identity my life was not
pendant on Rugby
I don't know I don't know what else I'll
do but I think I'd grow enough enough
and been through enough with rugby in my
own life to be like
I'm more than just a rugby player so if
I have to walk away or they don't sign
me or whatever then
I'll be okay
um
and then that allowed me to stay strong
be like nah man like make your own
decision inform yourself
like the club they're gonna do what they
have to do which is within their
protocol and they're not bad people
that's just what they're doing
but you you are your own human being you
can make your own decision like and and
but inform yourself so you're aware and
educated of the risks and stuff and then
how did you go from obviously having
this idea
um to creating the business you
obviously we're doing it while you're
playing how hard was that to juggle
um often talk to guys about life after
rugby and how hard it is to sort of get
into anything before you've actually
finished your career but how did you do
it yeah I think um
one thing I've learned about life after
rugby and like having this business and
just being my bloody
full ripping into orders
I think we do take for granted how much
free time we get as proficient rugby
players and you know we're bloody good
at going for coffees with the boys
becoming [ __ ] Masters on Playstation
um and so what my time became
um
kind of like a moose than outside rugby
was like learning about
the CBD industry and and really it was
happening because
I didn't have a business idea at this
point it was I just wanted to take it so
I was trying to inform myself what the
risks were so I was like calling up
world anti-doping because you know as
Pro players that know like we're they're
very accessible when you're like a
contracted player you can call them up
ask them about different supplements
testing protocol all sorts so I'd be
like calling them up asking them about
the testing methodologies what the risk
elements were for taking these type of
products uh and then I would be emailing
and calling like Brands CBD Brands uh
manufacturers at this point CBD wasn't
like I hadn't really gained any traction
in the UK it was still it was in America
where it started to kind of you know be
a really growing industry
um so I was contacting people over there
I do think like being a current
professional player may be allowed more
opportunity you know like they were
probably a bit more inclined to speak to
me potentially I feel but I'm not
certain on that
um
and so yeah I found that these people
were pretty accessible I was calling up
like
the different brands asking for advice
asking would they send me their lab
report so I could look at them
I ended up getting in touch with
different manufacturers in America
asking about their extraction methods of
searching and learning about all sorts
of how the products were extracted and
stuff
and then along the way throughout all
those phone calls I was like it became
quite clear to me
that what I'd Learned was well one it
was obviously there was no fully batched
tested and certified under like an
accredited uh accessing agency uh range
of CBD products for athletes but two
there was also a lack of trust and
regulations and there was quite a stigma
obviously because these products are
extracted from the cannabis plant
and so what I realized was like [ __ ]
I've searched everywhere for the summer
I've learned all this stuff
I should start the world's first fully
batch system and certified range of CBD
products not just for athletes but
because there's a lack of trust in this
industry
I know these products can benefit people
from all walks of life because everyone
benefits from a better sleep
everyone knows what it's like to have
joint pain or muscle pain that you know
they want relief from through
anti-inflammatory pain relief everyone
you know knows what it's like to have
like stress or a busy mind and can you
know have help feeling more focused and
clear so
that's when I guess my business mind
came to life that I didn't really know
that I had and I was like
if I can create this and use Sport and
this batch testing these will actually
be the most certified
transparent scientifically tested range
of CBD products in the world and that's
not just for athletes that that provides
trust for everybody
and then then there was two elements in
my mind it was like okay well one
athletes are not good customers pro
athletes because we we get given
supplements for free we get our boots
and all sorts for free and there's also
a very small population that are pro
athletes so I can't have a business plan
that's targeted as athletes as my
customer
but by providing the solution to
athletes
I can utilize the sporting angle to
provide trust to the wider audience who
are still needing education who are
looking for trust in this new industry
and with these new products so yeah man
I I ended up calling one of these
manufacturers or two of them actually
and I said this is what I want to do
then I called up bscg which is banned
substance control group who are the
certifying agency
and I had said because there's two main
ones in film Sport and bscg the level of
testing it's all exactly the same the
the outcome of a certified product is
the same under both
um but they're both wider compliant
Olympic compliant so I spoke to him
about could they do CBD uh and I spoke
to informed sport as well inform sport
couldn't didn't have the equipment and
uh we're not doing CBD bscd said they
could
so spoke to this this manufacturer and I
just was like because in order for the
brand to come to life it had to get the
certification I could buy the raw
material have them manufactured if they
didn't pass I was [ __ ] because it
wasn't the USP that I was trying to
create
so pretty much I what I did to vet who I
was going to have these products uh
created by
because there's two elements to the
manufacturing you get the raw extracted
material which was extracted from the
cannabis plant so there's hemp Farms
that grow it
and then they will have extraction
methods that extracted in a certain way
and then you buy the raw material then
you have a contract with the final
product manufacturer under certain
specifications to create the final
product so there's two elements to the
manufacturing site I went to like
multiple different manufacturers I said
okay
payment terms of this order are on it
being certified I say I'll pay a deposit
up front and then I'll pay in full when
it gets a certification
and the majority of these managements
are nah can't do that and what that said
to me is they don't back the methods
that they're using to be like a specific
you know because I needed it to be
exactly what they said yeah and then
what allowed me confidence was there was
the one manufacturer that was like yep
sweet I'll do that so I knew they backed
their extraction and the clarity that
they had through that
uh and then same again with the raw the
final product manufacturing they were
like yep cool and so that was how it
came to life and I actually utilized
like a consultant
um to
help me kind of throughout the whole
process because like I'm not a scientist
like you know I'm just doing it on from
my YouTube researchers and I can talking
to people on the phone so I wanted to
make sure these were the best because
another part of my obviously like idea
was well if you're targeting athletes to
promote these products and use them to
then hit the wider audience these
products have to work
because athletes are not going to take
that doesn't work that's not we're not
like it's not gimmicky when it comes to
this stuff
so I had to I wanted to ensure that they
were the best possible out there
back then I didn't understand business
at all like margins and so like the
product margins were like not good they
weren't like commercially that viable
but it didn't matter like I had this USP
and it wasn't until we sort of grew that
I was able to like scale up the supply
chain to command like better pricing and
stuff like that that you know
commercially it became more viable but
what I've also learned is in the early
days of a business it's not about being
profitable it's about growing and
building your brand and your reputation
um
so yeah that was that was it really and
then when Once the products got made
I just started an Instagram page I had a
really simple humble website that I got
a third-party developer to create for me
and
because by this point people had become
aware and Sport about CBD because you
had like NFL guys talking about it UFC
fighters different publicity about it
people were interested
and when I launched it as the world's
first certified it was like I had an
inbox full of like [ __ ] dudes that I
like thought you know that I knew I knew
a lot of them and then a lot of them I'd
watched on TV and you know
very International Rugby players from
all around the world and
for the first two years I didn't put my
name to the brand because the club I was
with I wasn't allowed to take it or
promote these products it was on the
beach of my contract
and then also in my mind I was also like
I don't want people to think these
products are not as good as they are
because I'm just a rugby player because
I put everything I've used these
scientists but the certification
I don't want people oh that's just
somebody rugby player clown making these
products like they're so one because of
the club
and my contract not being able to talk
about it and two because I didn't want
it to kind of people to think it wasn't
as good as it was
so I was like replying to dudes that I
knew like guys that I'd played with and
who you know they're like hey bro which
one do you and I'd be like oh yeah mate
you know like put on this like hi there
yeah so this is a great one
um yeah it was uh it was it was good fun
mate I love how you've just self-taught
yourself everything from just YouTube
like you've said yourself you're not a
natural businessman uh you haven't had
the education of you know your marketing
degrees and all this sort of stuff
you've just literally self-taught found
a product that you've really packed and
just jumped right in and learned on the
way I love that I love hearing stories
like that but one thing about like we
spoke a little bit about the marketing
have you what have you learned on that
marketing side of things you've
obviously
um used professional rugby athletes to
be sort of ambassadors for you or people
to promote the product you also have
other athletes as well how do they sort
of compare what have you learned from
the marketing side of things yeah I
think like one thing I've I've learned
is if you believe in and are so
passionate and like authentic about what
your product is it's so easy to talk to
people and like share that excitement
with them and people people get on board
with it I think there's so many what
I've learned about businesses people a
lot of business
people
identify an opportunity in an industry
as an opportunity to make some good
money and grow a good good business but
it's not maybe necessarily something
they're truly like aligned with
so I think one of the our biggest
strengths was like
I the stuff generally you know sounds
cliche but it generally changed my life
you know uh and so to have that
excitement
and then also I think I had this like
fire in my belly about being told nah
don't take that especially after seeing
my teammate and what the path I was
going on I had almost like this firing
me to be like well you know
who are these people to tell me no like
so I kind of almost like there was a
spit within me that was like you know as
a kid I was a bad student I always got
in trouble I couldn't pay attention and
so I've always had this thing of like
well I want to prove people wrong like I
want to do something good and I want to
show them that nah just because you say
no like that's not the only way so
getting people on board and just word of
mouth was our biggest marketing from the
get-go
um and naturally rugby players were
within my network and and and uh they
were like people that got jumped on
board with this early and then that
spread out into wider athletes and then
also like what we learned was I I'm not
sure what it's like in New Zealand at
the moment but uh in Europe UK there's
like a huge number of like online
fitness
influencer type people who
some of them are bloody a bit of a joke
and they're just in it for like building
their following and making quick bucks
from endorsements but there are a lot
who are actually very very genuine about
the lifestyle and helping people and
living more optimally and I found that
like these people were amazing advocates
for these products because the people
that were following them followed them
because they wanted to learn about
living optimally
and then so we went going into that
space what I learned about rugby players
is one
rugby players are rugby players that's
our bread and butter like we're not
influencers you know
and then learning about the skills and
knowledge that influence the type people
had in comparison to rugby players was
like vast you know like I was sort of
um it wasn't until like six months in
when I was like [ __ ]
and like
all these dudes are buying my products
and then like just because they're good
dudes or they like the products they're
tagging them and sharing them one day
you know I'm not like this is how
humble the learnings have been for
people like there's no business
Mastermind here one day I got the
shipment of products and they hadn't
packed them properly and all the labels
got damaged so they had like scratch
marks and you know we're our products
are not cheap because they cost a lot of
money to make in the lab testing
and that people are paying good money so
in my mind I'm like the whole service
has to be the best that can possibly be
so when I had these scratched and Chip
labels I I went back to the people at
the warehouse and I was like look man
like you need to re-label these and then
they were kicking up a big fuss and all
that size up I I then had this idea okay
you discount these by this amount and
you discount that amount off my next
order and then we'll call it even like
okay so the end of my mind I was like
okay they've discounted sale or
something like 30 so I was out here so
I've got 30 of this order
that's free to me now I'm gonna gift 30
of this stock to athletes so then I was
going to I was like you know hey bro
drone I think it means a lot for me that
you guys tag these here man I'm gonna
send you guys these products and then
same with Danny Cipriani and then some
of these other guys Finn Russell and
these guys they're like oh yeah bro
thanks man and then you know they'll
just do a few more stories and tags and
what they'd normally do
and then I was like oh [ __ ] like
you'd start to see growth and more sales
coming in and questions and eat people
emailing oh how I saw this print all
right there you know what one would you
recommend so I was like oh [ __ ] like you
know that's marketing okay cool and then
so I was like the more people see these
and get in front of them the more
people sell it more sales
so that was my accidental like Venture
into marketing and and I guess what I've
learned about rugby players is people
follow rugby players because they are
fans they love the team and they love
the player because it's That's
Entertainment to them
I think in my position what I've learned
is they don't necessarily follow
rugby players because they want to live
a lifestyle like them because the
lifestyle to them is not as it's not
achievable like a normal like the 50
year old dude who loves sinking pints
and watching the All Blacks down at the
pub
uh and talking to you know telling
people back in my day you know when I
was already there's that in the other
um
they they're not aspiring to train and
live like dream kind of you know but
they relate to it because they're like
oh yeah I gotta [ __ ] me as well okay
he's taking that instead of painkillers
I'm gonna try it but the the core of the
following is not following these guys
because they're influenced by their
Lifestyles but then what I found with
these Fitness people is the core of
their following follow them because they
want to learn from them how to live more
openly how to train better how to sleep
better how to eat better
so I started to see way more traction
with these influence and and also these
influence type people I hate calling
them influencers because the ones we
work with I wouldn't class them as
influence of the actually genuine about
what they do we call them ambassadors
but they're professionals at creating
content educating people on things
displaying their lifestyle what I found
with rugby players is
the majority it would just be a photo of
the product be like you know I love this
product helps me sleep better which is
is great because the impact comes from
the platform that they have the trust
the level of what you know the fact that
these guys are drug tested once a month
and then they have to put good trusted
things in their body
and also people kind of know that
they're No Nonsense they're not going
around just promoting [ __ ] for the sake
of it you know
um
so there was pros and cons but I guess
from my biggest learning is
I feel that professional rugby players
can offer so much more in terms of
their own strengths as to their
endorsements I think what I've seen
through my journey four years now of
pure sport is Brands I think like like
rugby players are doing so much amazing
things for Brands like Adidas Nike Essex
all of that and very very few rugby
players are actually making any
lucrative money from these types of
endorsements yet they're [ __ ] wearing
it they're only allowed to wear that
brand that they're supplied with don't
be wrong you get the odd guy here and
there that might get a little retainer
or something like that and then you get
the top one percent you know like the
sunny bills and Dan cars you get paid a
significant sum of money for their
endorsement
but what I've learned is I feel rugby
players can be so much more savvy
and create a platform
and create good content educate people
on who they are their lifestyle draw
more people and and through that they
can actually one earn some good money
aside from their contract but by doing
these things set themselves up really
nicely after rugby networks so that
that's probably my biggest learning
there I love that because that that is
so that's so true but you also mentioned
about Scotland even though you'd created
your own product and you weren't allowed
to take it or advertise it at all even
though it was your own thing so there's
so many rules within rugby that do stop
players from yeah and being able to
create their own things or being able to
advertise things you even spoke about
Adidas and the restrictions players have
with Adidas and wearing other brands and
things there there's so many rules that
stop players and being able to make an
extra dollar like you say but yeah it is
a very interesting space and I agree it
it'd be good to see players do a lot
more of what is it in particular is
anyone doing it um well anyone that you
think man he's doing awesome in this
space I think like Quade Cooper's pretty
great at like uh
building his own profile through his
social media yeah I think Kaelyn ponger
is he's an example of a guy who
unbelievable Talent making like big
bucks through his contracts but you can
tell he has interests and things that he
wants to do outside of the game
that uh you know I I feel like if you do
have these interests and you can express
yourselves it's going to actually help
you to be a better player because when
you're injured or maybe your form's not
so great it's not like all your eggs are
in one basket you know and I used to
believe that and I think the world of
sport kind of points you towards oh you
need to be all out all focus and it's
true like you gotta do you got to look
after yourself you've got to train right
you got to do your analysis you got to
eat right you got to be focused in
prison in that moment your body has to
be fresh and looked after to perform
but
guys it's been so much time playing
PlayStation or working chilling eat
drinking coffee which is all that's fine
but it shows there is so much time to
like utilize to learn and evolve and I
think
um I mean off the top of my head I mean
I said great but I can't think right now
of any one particularly in rugby but
your dog ADI yeah yeah exactly and there
you go he's an amazing example man like
and it shows now because there's
companies like Roc Nation who are
signing guys like ADI and Sia Khaleesi
Marcus Smith
um
and it's allowing them to utilize the
platform and who they are as an
individual and an athlete
to bring in meaningful endorsements but
build their profile for Life After rugby
too and I just think that it's not
promoted enough within sport because in
this day and age we're in like building
the profile that you've got through your
professional sport
and the opportunities you can create
around that and then develop like what
you've done of the podcast and you know
what I've been able to do and it's only
the beginning for us both but without
with pure sport
it shows man like there are so many
opportunities for us alongside our
playing career that doesn't actually
take away from our playing crew it
actually gives to it so I think we need
to break that mold of
uh bro I started a podcast when I was at
Glasgow Warriors and the coach came up
to me Gregor Townsend and he was like oi
make sure you focus on Rugby and like
grow that just that one comment
and bro I was so committed man to my
training and wanting to play and perform
and that one comment was like well [ __ ]
I better stop the podcast because that
guy who's in charge of my destiny thinks
I don't care it's so true like that
should that's not right bro you know
what I mean yeah mate I I was I felt the
same like even I didn't set up my
podcast until I was finished because I
knew if I wasn't playing well it would
always come back oh you're spending too
much time on your podcast and you know
what chat there's a lot of changing room
Banta in a rugby team like if you're
really putting yourself out there when
you're doing these things and some guys
won't like it and you'll you'll cop it
for it even though it is I'm just all a
little bit of fun it does eventually get
to you I think so and there's still
reasons why people don't do these things
I think yeah and and it comes back to
what we were chatting at the start about
like the the we need to break that mold
and those like outdated traditional way
of what how you should act as a rugby
player because that that perspective is
no longer in service of the game or the
individuals you know
and
although I agree like most of the
majority of it is fund banter from your
own teammates and stuff but it's
actually coming arising from that place
of
this is how you should act
even though it's been expressed in a fun
playful way it's like hey bro like stay
in your lane you know I seen when I was
in my towards the end of my career the
younger players who had grown up with
Instagram and Tick Tock and school and
just creating content and expressing
themselves online was just part of life
we're not coming to the pro team at like
19 20 21 and they were just doing what
they do doing their posts and stuff like
that they were getting bullied and given
[ __ ] by the older players you know hey
[ __ ] we don't you know stay in your lane
bro you don't have 50 Games Shut the
[ __ ] up like
um
and some of it was joked then someone
was actually bullying but regardless
made that person second guess like
expressing themselves yeah and that's a
problem to me so
like I said I do think the New Zealand
Rugby side of things people like your
podcast I think what Isaac John's doing
with yktr uh Quaid
um Caitlyn pong with the Arty
is sort of breaking that mold so I hope
that the organizations can get fully on
board with it and understand that it's
actually going to help their business be
better by having more exciting and
interesting characters
uh who feel comfortable to express
themselves and like I hope they support
and encourage that because for the
future of rugby as just the business I
really think it's that's really really
necessary yeah and you even spoke about
that like towards at the start of the
podcast as well where you mentioned
um like the characters and getting in
Behind These players and you say
um UFC do it so well and rugby could do
better but it is the players like I fell
in love with the Hurricanes because I
loved Christian Cullen I loved the way
he played and now they've been my
favorite team for the rest of my life so
it was that initial character who I fell
in love with and I think like you say
rugby players like some of those
examples are really good guys who are
making young kids fall in love with them
then they become attached to that team
like you say so I don't think too many
teams other than if your family is like
hard out Crusaders or something I don't
think too many players will just love
the Crusaders for the fact that they're
the Crusaders that someone in that team
it's the Richie Moana or the will Jordan
and side who makes them fall in love
with that team yeah absolutely man and
like people want to know more about
these dudes people don't want to just
hear like we said let's start that that
two minute interview about you know your
credit to the boys you know like
like yeah do the post-match interview
but like
create opportunities like heaven and
house podcasts for each team like have a
character like yourself who loves it who
can host the podcast for the team and
like
interview the boys and the the boys know
you can just be yourself bro
that's you're not going to get you're
not going to get [ __ ] dropped if you
say this or that bro like UFC I'm not
saying it would go to this extent but
like those dudes I can like swear it and
like [ __ ] on that Dana White dude who's
like the main guy and he loves it bro
he's like [ __ ] laughs he's like what
did you think about this guy saying
you're an [ __ ] and he's like oh yeah
he's entitled about life as long he
shows up and puts on a good display I'm
happy he's like oh he'll go back and be
like yeah but he's a [ __ ] like I
don't know and it's like you know yeah
like that that's to an extreme I'm not
saying you know America is their own
kind of fish but yeah it shows people
love it man they're a die-hards for that
stuff like and then they're going off
chatting about it everybody buying the
clothing like so
yeah for me it just shows professional
sport for it to be an appealing business
in this day and age has to be more than
80 minutes and that that comes down to
the players and allowing that more
freedom couldn't agree more and
hopefully uh we do see a bit more of a
buy-in but one thing I am really Keen to
talk to you about is the New Zealand
launch of pure Sports so
um talk to me about this yeah man I'm so
excited bro like obviously you know New
Zealand born and raised
um
and then you know hugely
driven by what we're doing with pure
sport but obviously you haven't been
able to
uh launch our brand fully in New Zealand
like we were able to uh ship products in
from our UK website
um but
because of different like regulations
and stuff like that in New Zealand
currently we can't actually like stock
and fully have a website and launch and
New Zealand um
but because of the regulation still in
place in New Zealand around CBD products
where pure sport is currently is uh
along the way we we began to innovate
and create some really exciting products
that didn't contain CBD so there's a
huge wave uh and a huge amount of
research and
um excitement around
mushroom-based supplements
and these are like ingredients that have
been used for bloody you know
millenniums by indigenous people and
stuff and
but the education and science behind
them are starting to come to the fall
now and um
I mean my first awareness around the
benefits of mushrooms was I actually
when I was at Glasgow Warriors oh sorry
so before I go into so we're actually
able to launch our nootropolis
adaptogens and mushroom-based products
in New Zealand uh and that's going to be
sort of in the next four to six weeks
which like I'm so excited about hope I'm
hoping I can come back home it's gonna
be my first time in a long long time to
do this launch and but yeah we're going
to have a New Zealand website
puresport.co.nz Instagram gonna do like
you know uh endorsements with different
um individuals to promote the products
um look to be stopped in different uh
retailers and stuff like that we'll have
a fulfillment like a warehouse setup
that holds our products so that the
shipping when people order arrives
quickly uh there's no worry about like
the customs and getting stopped and all
the and tax duties and all of that
um so man I'm so excited but just to go
back there around the mushrooms so so
nootropics is a name for natural
ingredients that have like cognitive uh
enhancing
um benefits adaptogens are a name for
natural ingredients that help your body
to adapt to the current necessity so say
if you're stressed it'll help you you
relax if you uh need to sleep better
it'll help with Sleep Quality pain
inflammation will help your body adapt
and the majority of these ingredients
are
mushroom-based ingredients then there's
other sort of like enzymes like CoQ10
l-theanine which like interact naturally
with the body and naturally derived
substances and the whole idea behind a
lot of these products is to help you
optimize your body so we have one called
boost which is a natural energy and
immune boosting um supplement we have
our de-stress which is a like cognitive
function Focus stress relieving product
a bit of unwind which is
um a sleep enhancing natural and capsule
we have the Mind Body mushroom complex
which is like an antioxidant and
cognitive function helps with like the
degeneration of neural Pathways to kind
of prolong good
brain health uh then female balance
helps like woman's Hormone Health and
helping with just sort of overall
Women's Health
these are products that man I'm so
excited about uh and my immersion into
some of these mushrooms and nootropics
there was a point at when I was at
Glasgow Warriors that I had three
concussions in a year quite close by and
the last one I was struggling to recover
I was having headaches and all sorts and
the club sent me to like this
neurologist Studios like this highly
qualified neurologist and
to kind of help give me guidance on how
to recover and he talks about all sorts
like cutting out screen time he spoke
about doing some forms of meditation
that help on the mind to relax and help
the like inflammation in there
and then he and then he goes oh and you
should start taking these supplements
that are mushroom supplements because
there's a lot of studies coming out
around how they help repair neural
Pathways and help with inflammation in
the brain uh and antioxidants I was like
okay at the time I was sort of not
really that at all I was like oh yeah of
course but I bought them started taking
them
but so that was when my first kind of
awareness of these and then as I got
into peels where I started like doing
more and more research
I I saw that there was a lot of studies
coming out around psilocybum which was
the scientific name for magic mushrooms
and obviously these are famous for like
the Psychedelic effects like you know
people having these mad trips and
hallucinating and stuff yeah
but these studies were showing that if
psilocybin was taken in a micro dose
which wasn't didn't have any
hallucinogenic effects
it was helping with cognitive function
it was being seen to have unbelievable
effects on people's mental health people
who are suffering with depression were
like being cured uh issues with like
concussions and head knocks um there
were some amazing results around that
but just like every day like Focus
Clarity of Mind creativity and since
then like learning about they'll keep an
eye on it and I started to immerse
myself more into some of these legal
because psilocybin still like a you know
illegal substance and all these studies
are very controlled and
when I started to immerse myself more
into like ingredients like lion's mane
reishi chaga uh
cordyceps
astragalus these are all names for these
functional legal mushrooms that have
different benefits in the body
and
um
you know very much so a lot of it was
around like relieving inflammation uh
stress but also the studies around how
these products ingredients had the
potential to repair neural Pathways in
the brain which for us who face all
these head knocks and stuff that's
pretty scary some of the retired players
now you know
um
facing things like dementia and symptoms
of dementia down the line and all that
so
learning about this stuff was pretty
amazing and these are a lot of the
ingredients in these products like the
Boost unwind de-stress female balance
that are formulated and targeted at
specific
benefits that we're going to be
launching in New Zealand and the timing
is amazing for these because people are
more aware if more educated more
empowered than ever to look after
themselves and choose natural
alternatives over these quick fixes
so yeah man I'm I'm so excited to have
pure sport in New Zealand it's like been
a dream for since we started yeah
exciting time so how do you get your
pure sport how do you get pure sport
into New Zealand because a question that
comes up heaps for me and my inbox is
like people try to get CBD in into New
Zealand and often get stuck in customs
sent back don't get your money how do
you guys get your CBD product into New
Zealand yeah so so currently like the
New Zealand regulations clarify
CBD as having traces of THC in it like
that's what the way in which uh New
Zealand regulate and explain what CBD is
that a CBD but it's got a small traces
amount of THC which is the psychoactive
compound our products have no traces of
THC whatsoever
so they don't actually fit under that
exact criteria that New Zealand
clarifies as CBD so it's almost like a
slight gray area
um
so that's what is allowing these
products to go to to get to people
um and with no issues yeah it's it's
only a matter of time until New
Zealand's one of the last sort of movers
in terms of opening up to like you know
CBD being available uh
over the counter and to be ordered from
websites and stuff like that and yes
it's it's just I know you know New
Zealand they take their time of certain
things and we had the referendum around
cannabis uh which was more so around
like recreational like THC cannabis
um that didn't go through which is
completely understandable you know it's
a big step to go from that being illegal
to them people just being able to walk
around and buy it and smoke joints so
hopefully what the next phases they re
they see that the rest of the world is
benefiting and it's a great industry and
uh they they can kind of jump on board
and just open up completely but yeah in
the meantime people are having using our
products and ordering them from here
with no issue but I'm excited about you
know these mushrooms and nootropics
because
you know that we've been innovating in
developing these products you know the
mushroom ones and stuff for like two
years now
um and the the sales and the benefits
and the reviews have been unbelievable
and I think I feel that the future of
these natural supplements will be moving
more
you know pure sport in two years time
will be selling the majority of
mushrooms and nootropics uh and you know
CBD will always be a staple element of
what we do
but because of the awareness and the
education that people are receiving
around them now it's
gonna kind of Swing the the scales the
other way so to launch our brand with
these products I'm hugely excited about
and I think the New Zealand Public are
people that are open-minded and care
about looking after themselves and doing
things in a natural way I think it's in
line with our culture
uh so yeah man I'm I can't wait right
exciting times exciting times for Pure
Sport and New Zealand having these
quality
supplements on the doorstep now you
won't have to wait a week or two to get
it shut they'll be there probably
overnight knowing your service always
Top Notch but as always we have gone to
our Instagram for some questions
um I did check it out late but we have
got a few good ones coming uh first
question this person obviously listened
to the first episode but he said how
hard is it dealing with being touted the
next best thing and then dealing with
the fact that you're not going to be oh
that's sad that's a sad question
I know I thought the same thing um but
it does happen heaps hey like there's
all these young kids now especially with
the rate that Schoolboy rugby is getting
filmed there's so many guys touted as
that next big thing and there can only
be so many next big things it's
happening all the time at rugby and you
were a big thing but
you were a good example of that in my
own mind and at the time I was doing all
right but now I think for me like
I um
I guess what what's being referred to
there is uh you know when I was a sort
of 19 years old made my old can debut uh
played all those games uh in that season
and we won the ram Philly shield and the
um
whatever it was called about their miter
10 cup I can't even remember this was in
2007 man [ __ ] that's what we know no I'm
old
um 2007. wow
um and then I got a I signed like a
long-term Blues contract straight off
there and then went to the under 20s won
the World Cup
still my claim to fame that my mates
give me a hard time for us uh I started
all those games ahead of Aaron Smith at
under 20 World Cup and uh
that was the peak of my career and sort
of went down from there but
now I I think what I learned was when
you get into a position that is an
amazing opportunity of you you've
literally worked so hard to get to
that is just the beginning
like it doesn't take care of itself
and I think
there was a
few different elements in my life like
you know
my dad passed away when I was 21 and
that was off something I was like you
know one of the most challenging things
I've ever faced in my life
he was a huge like part of what rugby
was to me like I shared rugby with him
uh
by even leading into that from when I
got my contracts and I was doing well
don't get me wrong like those in that
beginning phase I was so hungry so
driven
uh and which is why I was able to like
you know do well in that first season
for Auckland
make the under-20s get a blues contract
but all my dreams were coming true in
front of my eyes and and I actually had
this view in my mind growing up that if
I achieved my dream of getting a rugby
contract
I'm gonna be okay
I had a bit of an interesting and
colorful upbringing that I face a lot of
difficulties with
you know my dad having issues with
addiction and the life we live because
of his struggles so rugby to me was like
I'm gonna be good enough if I achieved
it
and when I got those contracts although
I was so excited and so proud I actually
didn't feel okay the way that I believed
I would
and what I down the line as my mind has
grown and evolved and understood things
better about how life works is
it's a myth it's like a mirage to
believe that anything material is going
to make you feel like a more fulfilled
human so I think that confusion that I
had
kind of I lost the Vigor and drive
because all of that drive was to feel
okay by achieving becoming a rugby
player because I had all my life I just
wanted to feel like
I was okay I was good enough you know
because I had all these issues and
feelings of lack and doubt and
you know feeling like oh growing up as a
poor dude and I grew up like with
nothing and my dad was you know had
addiction problems and there was
embarrassment around our house and car
and not having money and
and what that did for me as a young
person like
feeling I needed things to be okay was
wrong uh it has to start you know by
knowing in your heart like you who you
are is enough and then go out and do
what you love doing and and have
ambitions
so for me man I
if anything actually although I I'm one
of those dudes who every now and then is
like [ __ ] if only my mind stayed on it
what I could have achieved but Life's
too short to think that way and actually
what I look at now is
that that hardship that I went through
by not going you know like the blues cut
me because I wasn't playing well uh so I
went from like hero to zero in my
working neighborhood and with my friends
like
um and in my own mind too uh and at the
nightclub with the local girls in
Auckland
um and and but what although that was so
hard for me what it did was it allow me
to re-look at life and who I was and be
like Bro you've built Your Castle on
Sand here like
thinking that your values derived from
your contract or playing on the weekend
or being on Sky
uh there's no way to live and your shows
because it's not
it's not sustainable like like the
motivation wasn't sustainable uh and
that showed my training and stuff and
actually if I could go back in time
we'll be like oh
you love this game just love it like
that's what got you here as well like
so it's helped me in life though to be a
more rounded human and like appreciate
life more and I think I never forget
that now with pure sport
because pure Sport's starting to grow
now
into something that you know I always
had an ambition of what it could be but
I didn't actually know what that looked
like because I didn't know business so I
was like oh [ __ ] heaps people could buy
this product and like it could grow but
I didn't even know what it looked like
now that I see what it looks like to be
growing
I always remember I'm like hey bro
remember when this was what you were
like this path you're on as a rugby
player yeah and you got complacent or
you forgot what it was like that what
got you here
don't don't forget that appreciate it
enjoy the journey always remember why
you started this brand it's because you
love it you believe in it it's about the
quality it's about the people it's about
the impact and actually um I feel
grateful for those hardships I faced in
rugby uh because I'm probably under
playing it but I mean I went through
really hard times when I lost my
contracts and felt like my identity and
felt like a loser man and
but I'm I'm grateful for it now hey
powerful stuff what a what a start to
the questions one of the greatest
answers of all time love that one okay
next next question but it's still it's
still got one of my claims the fame that
I started over over Ezra at the World
Cup so uh I reckon two you should put it
on a uh one of these bottle steps who's
the unknown washer who started over
Aaron Smith at under 20 World Cup and uh
and no one will ever get that answer
though but I would I would you were a
gun
you were an absolute gun every right to
start a universe oh you were good anyway
next question uh what old what old
straws old Strawbridge the under 20s
used to tell me to follow through with
my hands in the past but I was all
risked to remember I'll just flick of
the wrist and he hated my passing bro
but I was like I'd argue and I was like
but strawsy like it's on the target mate
and he's like yeah but I can get your
hands here I'm like yeah [ __ ] me but
I'll just flicked the wrist that's what
I've always done right now but you know
we're doing our best
yeah anyway next question can you tell
us the story of offer and George mawala
and Bangkok that sounds like a good one
oh [ __ ] you know that one is a blast
from the past
so offer and George were we played at
the same Club Grandma Carlton and now
known as g-tik uh and a bloody great
club man did wonders for me love that
place
um
and Grandma Carlton would go on the
sevens tour every year to Bangkok and
I'd heard about these tools but my whole
journey with Grandma Carlton I was
already in the system with like Auckland
and stuff so I was never able to go on
these famous tours and dudes like Simon
Monroe and uh you know Dean Barton Dave
Thomas and these fellas would always be
going on about like you're not a true GC
Butler if you haven't been on this
Bangkok tour anyway the year that the
blues tore up my contract that was my
opportunity I was like I'm Free as a
bird I'm going to Bangkok
um
and the level of the sevens and that
wasn't very good and it was all about
just like going over and having a good
time but at that time
offer and George had just come out of
school and they're on the Auckland
Academy and these dudes were playing in
the premiums team and they were
absolutely carving up man like
you know offers this gentle giant who
spoke like a baby and uh would just
absolutely end dudes and um
George was just this dude who was a
Silent Assassin and
I don't think he'd ever done a day of
gym in his life but his guns and chests
were Giant and I'd never seen a dude who
would run down a field
thin people off while his upper body
wouldn't move he'd just look at people
and just his arm would move and they'd
like fly away you know unlike the old
Journal Army rugby on PlayStation one
like where Jonah would Justin Bieber he
was like that in real life anyway these
dudes were absolutely carving up and
they were like 18 at the time and they
came on this tour
and obviously with those like that we
carved up we won the con and we all went
out for the night out as a team and like
part of the night out we had to where
these fluorescent yellow Grandma Carlton
polos uh on the night out and all the
teams from the tournament went out in
their team polos
anyway we went into this one nightclub
and it seemed to just be all locals and
uh the few of the boys were like dancing
with the Thai girls and you know and the
club was packed out and one of the boys
are sitting around by the bar and a lot
of these Tigers I think they took a
liking to quite a few of the big sort of
Island Boys
um and they had some decent dance moves
you know the boys on the D Floor so
they're getting a bit of attention
and these local like Thai dudes they
didn't like it so they went up to one of
the boys who was sitting on the bar
and goes to him hey and at this point
myself and I signed Monroe and Carla was
on the opposite side of the bar and we
kind of were watching this happen
and a guy goes up to the one guy goes
hey get up get off that chair and the
dude's like oh look I've been sitting
here for ages but it's my chair
and then the dude goes [ __ ] get off
here and then the boy was like you know
the boy and Auntie was like well nah
[ __ ] you like why and so then that
started this altercation and then this
fellow pulls a gun out
of his pocket and waxed the dude in our
team across the chin and then even like
our whole team rushes oh yeah because
for most of us it looks like he's just
throwing a punch we no one realized it
was a gun and if I'm rushing this big
ball starts breaking out and all these
like Tidus just start jumping in
those broad breaks out in the end
because these you know the boys on the
team uh like [ __ ] ginormous they
start like laying into all these guys
and some of these titles have like these
batons that they've pulled out of
nowhere but he's like like batons that
they're hitting here with anyway few of
the tiger start getting it pretty well
dusted up so this guy shoots the roof
with his gun and it's like a movie bone
like it's everyone just starts running
all these people running around and
running and so all about that let's go
let's go let's go let's get out
and then as we're walking out
the guy with the guns just walking along
out holding his gun and I remember
looking at him and his kind of like holy
[ __ ] this is scary trying to keep my
corn just walk out like casually and
everyone just walk out these all these
Thai guys walking out behind us and I
remember as I walk up the stairwell the
guy with the gun hands it to The Bouncer
and laughs so then I'm like [ __ ] like
the setup is like it must like belong to
these guys it's like they're dang wow I
don't know yeah and then and then one of
the boys is so pissed that he just
outside of the club there we're all like
sorry sorry we're going yep all good and
there's one guy swearing it like people
and we're all just trying to clear them
away uh and then one of the boys just
swings at this guy
and it was like oh it's like life
flashing before our eyes because like
we're going to do he's got this other
guy's got a gun man like he's like oh
and it's out on this busy street and all
these guys start other Thai dudes as
they like this like they had this like
infrastructure
start running with bets so naturally
like you're trying to protect your mate
who's getting bashed by bats and all
sorts and you've got one eye on the guy
with the gun
and then you know like the dude's
getting a bit of a hiding we're trying
to jump in and from throw other guys off
from getting hit by bats
eventually the physio jumps on top of
the dude so they stop bashing as a lady
physio hither jumps on top they stop
bashing
and then
um but these other dudes just start
running at me offering George and
another guy named Richie yolk
and and they we just turn and look back
in these like four Dudes with bats
running at us and we're like [ __ ] run
and on the back of my shirt it's still a
joke these days we each had our nickname
and mine was Batman because of an
interesting story that happened with a
former ex-girlfriend of mine's dad and a
bat and like it wasn't a really
interesting story that few of my Blues
teammates found out about and named me
Batman and it was very ironic because
I'm running away with Batman on my back
me offer George and Richie offers
running bashing this like there's a
car park of about 30 scooters that he's
like pushed them out the way running and
it was one of those ones that like I was
running because I was so close when we
saw them that like it was inevitable
that I was going to get hurt so I'm
running and I'm waiting for the bat to
whack me in the back of the head and
like knock me down but like the dude
must have felt for me or he must have
felt that the Batman on my back was
entertaining and he just ends up like
whacking me across the back and I was
like it was almost like a relief but I
was like ah like
anyway we get away
and get in this talk talk back to I
remember driving all of us crammed in
like offer and all of us and we're like
bro what the [ __ ] happened there
real worried about the guys that were
still back there
get back to the hotel like what do we do
do we go back how what are we gonna do
thank goodness like
the all the guys made it back today
because we're like bro like someone's
gonna die man like what are we doing we
can't leave them and uh everyone got
back safely
and that was a story and a tale I'll
never forget man but yeah uh that was a
interesting time and to this day man
when I see like offering George I'm like
boys remember that time bro I was like
[ __ ] these wouldn't have been all blacks
that we didn't make it we didn't survive
that bro but my Batman took one for the
team
my offer actually said because he shoved
us and I couldn't literally 30 scooters
out the way
this street we were running down was so
busy it was like one it was just a
packed Street of tourists and people and
this would have been a sight to behold
man like giants like offer and George
gassing down the street with like six
Thai dudes or bats chasing us it was
yeah
thanks thanks for bringing that one back
to the members I forgot about that oh
that is loose I wasn't expecting I was
expecting a loose yarn but not quite to
that extent that is one of the greats
okay next question this one is from
swish our major sponsor if you could get
a video shout out from any celebrity who
would it be and why
it's a good one bro
ah flip I'm a pretty small you'd have so
many no I'm like a quite a small-minded
guy when it comes to celebrities I'm not
like real well immersed
[ __ ] that's a good question
um uh it might sound pretty sad and
embarrassing because you know maybe my
horizons are not that big but
um
probably Reuben Wiki was like Bad Dudes
a little bit nice
dude yeah he would be a guy I like that
because he would do you a he would he'd
do you a pretty mean shout out hey here
you know it'd be it'd be pretty hearty I
reckon like hey River and the Warriors
need all the help they can get at the
moment cheapest he might as well come
back on ah bro the Warriors they're
always gonna be the Warriors are are
they I don't know but you got you just
gotta love the Warriors hard not to
either hard to support but you just have
to they'll they'll be better for when
pure sport arrive in New Zealand no
doubt yeah whereas my dream to one day
get the get the get pure sport on the
blues and the Warriors jersey that wow
honestly some people want like
some people want mansions in g-wagons
and I can all that I just want the pure
spoil on the Blues jersey and the
Warriors and maybe we'll get what a lad
on the shorts oh that will be living
right right too right I've seen those
I've seen them those rugby jerseys you
make but maybe we'll make a collab what
a LED pure sport rugby jerseys oh and
now we're talking yeah love it okay two
more questions biggest land in World
rugby
that is tough because there's so many do
you know who's actually a real lad who's
a [ __ ] great dude is um
Adam Ashley Cooper oh yeah he's a bloody
great dude man and he's a character like
and he's obviously had an unbelievable
career and
the longevity and the way and
consistency in which he played but I had
the uh Fortune of being his teammate for
two years and um
just a bloody lovely dude man
um
and just a real funny guy but just like
naturally you know just a a real
character and that fella would have some
some good Yarns to tell but he you
should get him on the podcast hey that
is a good shout actually I've had I've
heard a few people tell me that he is a
great lad so he might be someone I need
a Chuck on my last a set so many layers
to get through looking forward to trying
to get as many on as I can but last
question one piece of advice for a water
lad listener so we've been doing this
for a long time now but I don't think we
were doing this back in season one early
days when you came on so I've been
waiting this is a big reason why I
wanted to get you back on it's full of
advice full of great knowledge yeah I
um I like how I say yeah but I'm not
really full of knowledge um
but I I actually feel like I am
personally like very interested in that
um philosophical views and stuff and
because I'm trying to learn and
understand and evolve myself so by no
means do I think I'm qualified to offer
people advice and stuff but I love
learning myself but I think it takes it
back to what we said about
you know having almost in my so too many
people to use the world at my feet in
terms of my opportunity with rugby as a
19 20 year old and kind of that sort of
dissolving in front of my eyes I think
my biggest lessons in life are
first and foremost
like C and any given moment that like
you are
fulfilled as you ever will be no matter
what you've got what other people think
of you uh what achievements what
Ambitions you've got in mind
know that like you are fulfilled and
good enough now
and then go out from that space to go
after and do an express the things that
you you want to do and also I feel from
my learnings that will help you align
more to do things that are true to you
are because so often I think we have an
idea based upon like our cultural
conditioning or the world around us or
education or parents around what we
should do or who we should be and often
it's not actually in line with like
what's true to us so actually if you can
start from your point about no man like
I'm good I'm I'm fulfilled I'm as good
as I'll ever be
and within myself now nothing more no
more money no more contract no more
notoriety no house car girlfriend will
make me more fulfilled
then go out and express yourself and
what you'll find is
all from my humble experience and
opinion when I do see life in that way
I function better I interact better my
mind's clearer I'm better at problem
solving and seeing opportunities being
creative uh hardships don't seem so
definitive you know you feel pain and
sadness but you know it's part of life
um and that In This Moment like you're
you're good
um
so that's probably a bit of a
philosophical deep answer bro but that I
hope that resonates with even just one
person and then for me that's something
that's helped my life hugely could not
get a better answer than that one of the
greatest piece of advice we have ever
had on the podcast I knew you'd deliver
philosophical and all I love it perfect
awesome to have you back on the podcast
um got so much out of that I'm sure so
many listeners did awesome to get a bit
more insight into the pure sport world
what it's like being a business owner
trying to upscale a product and um take
over the world looking forward to the
launch in New Zealand and mate super
grateful to have pure sport as a sponsor
of what a lad it's been awesome to have
the partnership I I don't get sick of
getting messages of the feedback people
have from the product how it's changed
their lives so mate it's an awesome
thing that you're doing and mate um
awesome to catch up again ah thank you
so much bro love what you're doing
love having an alignment with you in
pure Sport and excited to get back and
get pure sport into New Zealand and yeah
man uh no place like home and I
appreciate you having me on bro
absolutely Ed
[Music]
it
[Applause]
[Music]